he names for the best scoring adaptation  and the original song score are Bedknobs  and Broomsticks song score by Richard M  Sherman and Robert B Sherman adapted by  Irwin Castel the boyfriend adapted by  peter maxwell davies and peter green  well Fiddler on the Roof adapted by John  Williams and Tchaikovsky adapted by  Dmitri chamku Willy Wonka and the  Chocolate Factory song score by Leslie  Britta's and Anthony newley adapted by  Walter Scharf and the winner is the  winner is John Williams  thank you I want to thank you for all of  us Sheldon Harnick and Jerry Bock for  their marvelous score on Fiddler on the  Roof which I think has enriched all of  our lives and for myself my thank-you  Lister's goes from here to the parking  lot but I do want to mention Norman  Jewison my Canadian friend  Isaac Stern and my colleague sandy  courage thank you very much